hello Co a family
I'm Greg Alba this is a Chara Kirk over
here how are you a charm
you actually pronounce my name very well
for the Thai pronunciation that's right
people
Greg knows everything Greg knows it all
you know what I found out that Nicholas
Cage is I'm atras mom's friends list
like when I say friends list I mean to
show friends and they have that yeah
there's been a couple of people who were
like you got a watch Nicholas Cage as
Darth Vader she loves Nicolas Cage so I
said okay I'll watch this with the Chara
alright achar are you ready I am so
ready for this
you'll get John soundproof headphones so
if I talk you'll look at me and go
uh-huh but you don't know what I'm
saying
[Music]
soon again this all still dancing
[Laughter]
yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] mom what do you say we cut the
chitchat
a halt you're the [ __ ] reason this
country's going down the drain
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
no these Nic Cage movies Buell Center
students when they you you've on you
business certain way and then that's it
I saw you and you saw me don't pretend
like you don't know who I am girl
[Music]
holy verse bees where does this gets out
it for generate sympathy for the
rebellion in the center don't you see
that's what she was there for that was
the plan to give you a lower your sad
devotion to that ancient religion has
not helped you conjure up the stolen
data tapes or given you clairvoyance
enough to find the rebels hidden
[ __ ] your crossing
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow very angry Nicolas Cage wow that was
a lot of Nic Cage right there that's a
lot of Nic Cage you ever seen any of
these before would like the Darth Vader
mixing of like Sam Jackson or Donald
Trump no yeah I've seen those I think
overall those are mixed way better there
were a few hilarious times here like the
especially one is interacting with
Princess Leia yeah I thought that was
the best part of it it's easy to say
like ooh be funny if we have this line
of Nicolas Cage go over here when
Nicolas Cage's audio is very like it
doesn't match with the body language at
all that's true so when his delivery was
a little bit more or less erratic the
Nicolas Cage lines I thought it worked
really well in those moments so I would
say it was like I'm kind of a mixed bag
but overall some pretty funny stuff in
there they would have had to go through
a movies oh yeah pull out the good part
to like have some semblance of sense
everything that's a lot of notes even
though I'm giving my criticism on it I'm
like that's still really Harvard yeah
you have to do here let me just looking
at the list here like how many movies is
this 1 2 3 4 5 6 13 movies plus one for
a new hope so that's like that's a lot
you have to go through yeah where's the
face loss piece off line I use the peach
line you know I can
eat a page for hours yeah that one
moving from face-off come on though it's
like the best Nicolas Cage yeah I mean
it's still fun anything Nic Cage would
make a good Star Wars villain especially
were Star Wars is headed now mix it up
with some Nic Cage in there have a lot
more fun like we we saw solo but I think
Nic Cage would have been a good
supplement for Paul Bettany's character
yeah nothing's by bad in the movie Oh
video man this is a fun video thanks for
recommending this guy so you guys can
now subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Belka subscribe
buttons don't work and you can check out
a Chara on the get Jabby channel that's
right
not the jab eco a channel the get javi
channel we're just trying to always get
Jabby yes like a Pokemon gotta catch em
all yeah fight